MALE SPEAKER: So good
afternoon, everyone.
And welcome to another
Talks at Google event.
And this event is very, very
near and dear to many of us
here at Google, the idea of
preserving cultural patrimony,
digitizing
manuscripts, organizing
the world's information.
In today's instance,
Joshua Hammer
is here to talk to
us about "The Bad-ass
Librarians of Timbuktu."
Now I do want to preface this
entire conversation by saying
that I personally think
that all librarians are
bad-ass in their own right,
but these in particular.
Joshua traces the
story of many heroes
who worked to preserve the
written legacy of Timbuktu
as the library was rent
ransacked during civil strife.
And so he will go
into that story.
He's also the author of
the numerous other books
and articles, including
and "Yokohama Burning."
And we'll have time for
some questions at the end.
So please join me in
welcoming Joshua to Google.
Thank you.
JOSHUA HAMMER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks a lot.
What I thought I
would do, and I've
honed this after a couple
of book talks in New York,
is give you a little rundown
of the arc of this story
and how I happened
to come to it.
And then I will accompany
that with some pictures
so you can get a sense of what
this very unusual, desolate,
but somehow beautiful
part of the world
is all-- what it looks
like, what it's all about.
And then I would read
a couple passages
and then ask if you
have any questions.
So Timbuktu-- how did
I come upon this place?
I was "Newsweek's" Africa bureau
chief in the '90s and kind of
had carte blanche to travel
all across sub-Saharan Africa,
basically doing whatever
I wanted to do in the days
when that kind of
journalism was still--
when news weeklies and
other media organizations
had deep pockets and could
let their correspondents just
wander the world.
So a couple of colleagues and
I in 1995 went to Timbuktu.
We chartered a small plane
in Bamako, the capital,
and flew up there for two hours.
Because it was expensive to
charter your own airplane.
And they weren't that generous.
So we flew in, and we
wandered the streets
of this ancient
town, desolate town.
There was a war going on.
The nomadic people known
as Tuaregs were in revolt.
And so there was basically--
there were no tourists.
There was basically no
transportation in or out.
We managed to get in
there, and wandered,
and saw the mud huts
where the explorers
from the early 19th
century had stayed
when they managed to get
into Timbuktu back then
and where one of them had
been executed after it
was found he was not a Muslim.
So it was a desolate,
kind of depressing place.
But also obviously had
this incredibly rich,
legendary history behind it.
And I was definitely hooked
right then and there.
Then 10 years later,
I left "Newsweek"
and went freelance and
began looking around
for ideas, always on the search
for ideas to keep working.
Came across a small item
about these manuscripts
from the Middle Ages that
had been rediscovered
in and around Timbuktu.
And the article went on to say
that there was an effort led
by a couple of librarians
to collect them--
I don't think the
digitization was yet part
of the process at that point.
But it was simply collecting
them and restoring them,
building libraries and trying
to show them to the world.
It definitely
caught my attention
given my previous
trip to Timbuktu
and my interest in literature,
and the preservation
of manuscripts, and
cultural patrimony.
Called an editor at
"Smithsonian Magazine,"
which does that kind
of thing-- exactly
what would appeal to them.
And within a week, I was on
another plane up to Timbuktu.
This is what I confronted.
This is the Sankore
mosque, which
was built in the 14th century.
The typical architecture
of that period,
when it was really a
unique architecture that's
sort of influenced by
the Egyptian pyramids
but given its own kind
of North African motif.
Streets look like that-- mix
of mud brick and limestone.
And better houses were made
of these limestone bricks,
as you see.
Mud alleys-- not the
kind of grand city
paved with gold that
had lured the Europeans
in the early 19th century.
Another shot of the oldest
neighborhood of Timbuktu--
Sankore, it's called.
During that trip, I met this
gentleman, Abdul Kader Haidara.
He was the most
charismatic figure
in Timbuktu in this
manuscript effort.
What he had done
single handedly,
practically, was to rediscover
this incredible tradition
of manuscript writing that
had flourished in Timbuktu
in the 15th and 16th centuries.
This desolate place
had 500 years ago
been at the center
of the commerce
and cultural life of that
period in Northern Africa.
It was a place where the
river met the desert, where
the highest bend
of the Niger River,
the third longest river
in Africa, met the Sahara.
So you had this constant
stream of transport,
of commercial transport,
coming from across the Sahara
Desert from as far away as
Europe, bringing textiles,
clothing, whatever they
could-- whatever came out
of that part of the world.
Then river traffic coming
up from sub-Saharan Africa
bringing everything from
kola nuts, to slaves-- it
was a big slave
trading port-- to gold.
So over the centuries,
this outpost
at the very edge of the Sahara
became an incredibly wealthy
place.
At the same time, under a
couple of enlightened rulers,
it became a center
of intellectuality,
of scholasticism.
Universities were founded in
the 15th and 16th centuries.
Thousands of students
came to Timbuktu
from all across the Arab world.
An industry creating manuscripts
it was founded around 1400,
or 1500, or so.
In between that period, you had
hundreds of scribes turning out
using beautiful calligraphy,
and beautiful colors,
and beautiful
pattern and designs,
works that range from Korans,
the Hadith, the sayings
of the prophet, to
secular works including
works of astronomy,
works of medicine,
poetry, guides to orgasm.
You name it, everything
could be found
in Timbuktu-- how-to books,
I should say-- how-to books
about sex.
That was a real popular
seller in about 1550.
So this incredible trade
flourished for 100 years
or so during this
golden era of Timbuktu.
It showed a kind
of Islam that was
tolerant, open, cross-cultural,
multicultural, open to ideas,
able to synthesize both religion
and science in a unique way.
It lasted, as I said,
for about a century.
And then in the late
16th century, about 1591,
Moroccan invaders swept across
the Sahara, conquered Timbuktu,
took many of these scholars
and scribes into captivity.
A lot of them were
resistant-- became
members of the resistance
against the colonial occupiers.
So they were either
killed or enslaved
and dragged across the
desert back to Morocco
where they spent either the
rest of their lives or years
in captivity.
That pretty much
ended Timbuktu's reign
as the center or scholasticism
of this part of the world.
At the same time,
cultural-- sorry,
trade routes were changing.
This whole desert trade was
no longer that important.
And as time went
on, Timbuktu kind of
faded into insignificance of
became this, as I have said,
this desolate outpost that
the Europeans stumbled
into in the 19th century.
And they got there,
as I said, having
heard these legends
about this city of gold
and stumbled upon this place
that was pretty much-- well,
you saw the pictures
before-- just a dusty,
poor, monochromatic,
pretty insignificant pace.
So there was tremendous joy
at having reached Timbuktu,
but at the same time
great disappointment.
Abdel Kader Haidara had a unique
story, a pretty extraordinary
story.
This gentleman was the son
of a scholar in Timbuktu,
became interested in Timbuktu's
lost literary tradition
as a young man, as a teenager.
And I should also point
out that not only did
Timbuktu become a desolate
place, poverty stricken place,
but the whole tradition
of literature,
of learning was lost to the
point where enlightenment
philosophers in Europe-- Hegel,
Locke, Kant-- wrote articles,
wrote books saying that the
Africans have given us nothing.
The Africans have given
us-- have no civilization,
have no written traditions,
were illiterate savages.
The Enlightenment
philosophers' views
were instrumental in
justifying the slave trade.
Because they
propagated this idea
that Africans were sub-humans.
And therefore, taking
them into captivity
was perfectly acceptable.
It should be pointed
out of course
that the people in Timbuktu
back then also participated
in the slave trade.
So this wasn't the specific
to the European point of view.
But anyway, Abdel
Kader was determined
to rescue this lost tradition.
So he was hired in 1984 by
the Ahmed Baba Center, which
was a government owned library
funded by the royal-- governed
by the royal families of
Kuwait and Saudi Arabia.
He was hired to go out-- he
was a bit reluctant at first.
He said to me, I want
to go into businesses.
His father had actually
become a fairly wealthy man
trading livestock and grain
as well as maintaining
his own private library.
Abdel Kader kind of leaned
towards the money-making side
of his father's career
but was persuaded
by the chief
librarian, who appealed
to his sense of national
duty and his love of books
to go out hit the road.
And this guy really
did hit the road.
He went out, spent
the next 12 years
of his life traveling by
camel, on foot, by riverboat
through desert along
the Niger River.
Let's just-- I
actually forgot to just
give you a little sense
of these books look like.
So let's quickly
flip through these.
And then I'll continue Abdel
Kader's story very briefly.
So this actually appears as
the end-piece in my book,
because I think it's one of
the most beautiful pieces.
I believe this is a Koran
from the 16th century.
And you can see gold leaf, earth
colors derived from minerals,
from insects, from plants.
Because of the prohibitions in
Islam against representations
of the human form, they
resorted to, instead,
these incredibly
intricate patterns
that were meant to
kind of demonstrate
the universality, the harmony
of existence under God.
And you have-- this is a book,
I believe, a diagram possibly
of poetry.
One of the things
about the manuscripts
is that very few of them have
been translated into English.
So unless you could
read classical Arabic,
you're kind of lost.
But you know, you
can still appreciate
the beauty these books, some
really extraordinary works.
I mean, and we're talking
thousands and thousands
of these.
So back to Abdel Kader-- this
is the kind of landscape--
this is the road to
Timbuktu if you could even
imagine there's a road there.
It's basically just
a sand track that
runs for 100 miles to the
very edge of the Sahara
from southern Mali.
Well, he was traveling for years
across this kind of landscape
getting clues about books.
You know, hey, I hear there's
a Qadi, a traditional judge,
in a village on the Niger
River 100 miles from Timbuktu
who has a box in a hidden
storage room which has
a Koran from the 12th century.
He would get these
clues, and then he'd
head off on these incredible
journeys that sometimes lasted
a month carrying lots
of cash, bargaining,
developed a keen sense the
worth of these volumes.
Again, more of kind of landscape
of this part of the world--
this is called La Dune
Rose, the pink dune,
along the Niger River,
a 90-foot sand dune
towering over the stream.
Traveling by riverboat-- a
little bit better than this.
I mean, they had motors
at least-- along the Niger
for days and weeks--
and managed to amass
an incredible collection--
by the end, personally
probably about 100,000 works
for the Ahmed Baba Center.
After that, he developed
his own library
based on the books that had been
in his family for generations.
By this point-- an
it was incredible,
the ultimate networker.
He had managed to
establish great connections
with European, Middle
Eastern, American foundations.
Money was rolling in.
Libraries were being founded.
By 2001, the sort
of golden age--
he had really recreated,
to a modest extent,
the golden age of Timbuktu.
There were 50 libraries,
377,000 volumes recollected
by Abdel Kader and other
librarians who emulated him who
he helped to acquire
funds from, as I
said, from Dubai, from
Kuwait, from Belgium,
from the Netherlands.
People were kind of excited
by this idea, you know.
Cultural, at this
time, was a time
to-- when people were
sort of rediscovering
the cultural bounty of Africa.
And so people were only
too happy to bring in,
to encourage this
the Renaissance.
Next stage in the story-- 2012.
Actually, let's take
it back to 2011.
There had been, simultaneous
with this Renaissance
in the desert, cultural
Renaissance, which also
included a musical Renaissance.
I don't know how many of you
are familiar with the music
of Mali, but it was
exploding not only
across Europe and to some
extent the US at this time,
but within Mali.
There was a festival
that had been created
in 2001 called The Festival
in the Desert to which
people like Robert Plant of
Led Zeppelin, Jimmy Buffett,
Bono were coming and playing.
And so this was
getting publicity.
And people were coming
from all around the world.
When I visited 2009,
5,000 Westerners
descended on this outdoor,
three and a half day festival
in the dunes west of Timbuktu.
I mean, it was an amazing
time in this desolate place
that I had visited
1995, completely cut off
from the world, transformed
in the course of less
than a decade into
this happening
town on the edge of the Sahara.
2011, the Arab Spring happened,
including the downfall
of Muammar Qaddafi.
In the years before
that, you had
this Islamic, Islamist movement
percolating in the Sahara
as Islamist movements tend
to do in parts of the world
where there is poor government,
where there's a lot of poverty,
where there's very
little infrastructure,
very little security.
Islamist extremists
love a vacuum.
And that's what the Sahara
and the area around Timbuktu
offered.
So in addition to
the fact that you
had Saudi money
pouring into this area
to try to encourage
the spread of Wahabbist
Islamist philosophy.
So that had begun to take hold.
Then you had a lot of
radicals from Algeria,
who had fought a
very nasty, bloody
civil war in the 1990s
coming into Mali,
kidnapping Westerners,
selling them for ransom,
making big bucks.
$116 million earned
by this group Al
Qaeda in the Islamic Maghreb
in between about 2004,
let's call it, and 2011.
That, in turn, allowed them to
buy weapons to recruit fighters
from across North Africa
and the Middle East.
All this was going
on simultaneous
with this cultural
flowering in the desert.
So you had these two
different dynamics
happening simultaneously.
What changed the whole
dynamic completely was 2011,
was the Arab Spring.
Getting back to that--
Qaddafi's regime fell.
You may remember in
the-- Qaddafi was killed,
I think, in July
or August, 2011.
The armories were
opened-- chaos.
NATO had been in there and
bombed the hell out of Qaddafi,
but nobody kind of thought about
what the consequences would be.
I think Obama said recently that
his biggest regret as president
was not foreseeing what
happened post-Qaddafi.
Well, this is what happened.
This was one of the many
unintended consequences
of the fall of Qaddafi, which
is that you had Islamists
flooding into Libya,
grabbing these weapons that
were basically free for
the taking in the armories.
And you also had these Tuareg
rebels, the nomadic rebels
who had been fighting
for generations
for their own independent
state in Northern Mali.
They got involved
in the act too.
These were secular
rebels, but they
found a commonality of
purpose with Al Qaeda--
all grabbed guns and
then in rapid succession
took over the North of Mali.
The government fell.
Timbuktu fell on
April 1st, 2012.
This is a photo of
a Sufi shrine, which
was destroyed by
Al Qaeda in July,
2012 as a foretaste of what
was going to happen in this.
As they declared
Sharia law, they
begin amputating hands
and amputating feet,
stoning people to death--
let me go back there--
and making life
extremely difficult
for the residents of Timbuktu
and across the north.
At this point, this is when
the final act of my story
unfolds, which is the
incredibly elaborate though
low-tech smuggling operation
that Abdel Kader Haidara then
engaged in, because he
believed that at some point--
although they had not
specifically threatened
to destroy these
manuscripts, he was
all but certain that the
jihadists at some point
would target them.
Because he saw what
they stood for, as well
many other people saw, as
anathema, as heretical,
as antithetical to everything
that is in accordance
with Wahabbist philosophy.
So Abdel Kader then embarked
upon this incredibly elaborate
effort using a network of
smugglers, volunteers, fellow
bad-ass librarians,
relatives, et
cetera to smuggle these by road,
by boat along the Niger River
to the safety of Bamako.
The last stages of this
period were in early 2013
when the French military
invaded the country.
And then the whole
North became a war zone.
So the final act
was the continuing
the smuggling operation
as French troops
and French aircraft were bombing
the hell out of the North,
destroying the jihadis, but
also putting these manuscripts
in grave, grave danger.
These are some shots I
took about four months
after the French invaded
and swept the jihadis out.
In their final act of vengeance,
exactly what Abdel Kader
foretold or feared what
happened in fact happened,
which was that the jihadists
grabbed every manuscript
they could find that was left
in the city and burned them.
And this is a picture
I took, again,
about probably-- let's see.
Let's say August,
2013, so about six
months after the
war in the North
ended and the jihadis had been
thrown out of Timbuktu and out
of the cities into the desert--
many killed, some still around.
But in their final act, this
is what they left behind.
This is the Ahmed
Baba Institute,
the government
owned library, which
they attacked and gathered
every manuscript that
had been left behind, that Abdel
Kader had been able to save,
and destroyed.
And this is the
aftermath of all this.
This is what happened.
This is what's basically
keeping Timbuktu safe right now
are these guys.
This is a West African
peacekeeping force
under the United
Nations umbrella.
These guys were leaving
Timbuktu in August, 2013
after serving a few months.
They were going on.
I think these guys are
from the Burkina Faso.
And I was heading
across the Niger river
to visit Timbuktu to start my
reporting on this book project.
And you can see-- kind
of an interesting shot.
Guy over here thinks he's
storming the beach at D-day.
But they basically
were and continue
to be the only security
that this desolate city has
protecting it.
That essentially is
the arc of the story.
Now I just thought I'd
give you a little bit
of a sense of the book.
I'm going to read a
couple-- I've been
going for about 33 minutes.
So let me read two passages
from this book that
will kind of give you
a taste of Abdel Kader.
And the first one is, which I've
found has had a good response,
gives us a sense of
his bargaining efforts.
So Abdel Kader would
go out into the bush.
And he would bargain
with the locals.
As I said, he would
get these clues
about the existence
of these manuscripts
and would track them down.
And then he'd have to enter
into these negotiations.
It was a very difficult thing.
The first thing, people--
and I should point this out.
I don't think I mentioned in my
talk that people were fearful.
These manuscripts had,
over the centuries,
been disbursed through families.
There had been a succession
of attacks on Timbuktu
by 19th century jihadists.
The French colonizers had
come in and captured the area
and held it for 70, 80 years.
Manuscripts were highly
sought after by the French.
The French had grabbed and
stolen many beautiful works,
whisked them off to libraries
in Paris and then elsewhere
in France.
So by the time Abdel
Kader came around--
and I neglected to tell you
this part of the story, what he
was doing in the first place.
They had been dispersed
throughout the desert.
They had left their
original home in Timbuktu.
As I said, families
would pass them down
to generations of
sons and daughters.
So they would be dispersed
through the families.
And then because of this
fear of losing them,
they would be further dispersed
and buried in the sand,
and hidden in storage
rooms in villages and towns
all through the Niger, all
through upper Northern Mali.
So by the time Abdel
Kader came and had
to try to find these works,
there was a lot of fear
out there.
People were extremely
reluctant to surrender
what they viewed as
their family heirlooms
and valuable collection.
So he had a great
amount of difficulty
at first getting a
hold of these things.
But his techniques improved.
And he was able to
get more and more--
he was able to figure out
ways of encouraging people
and became more and
more successful.
So this is a typical scene
of Abdel Kader at work.
"People also sensed that
Haidara was playing fair.
After nearly being run
out of Gorma Rharous,
the first town he
visited, Haidara
returned there a year later.
On his first afternoon
back in town,
a Tuareg nomad in
his 40s, a gaunt man
in a ragged turban with
half a dozen children
playing around him in the
sand, called out to him
in greeting as he
passed by his tent.
'Come inside,' he cried.
Haidara entered the traditional
dwelling stitched together
from goat skins and sat on the
ground in the semi-darkness.
He noticed a metal
chest at the rear
of the tent, the type normally
used to whole manuscripts.
'You come from where?'
said the Tuareg.
'I'm from Timbuktu,'
replied Haidara in Tamasheq,
the language of the Tuaregs.
In addition to his
native Songhay,
he was conversant in
Peul and Tamasheq,
the two other main
languages of Mali's north,
as well as French, and
thus had no problem
negotiating with manuscript
owners across the region.
Haidara made small talk.
And seeing that the
Tuareg was too poor even
to offer his visitor
a cup of tea,
he offered to purchase
some food and drink
for him and his family.
Haidara ran out to the
market and returned
with half of slaughtered lamb
and a kilogram bag of tea.
The Tuareg grilled the
lamb outside the tent.
And as they sat eating in the
sand with the man's family,
Haidara gently broached the
subject of the manuscripts.
'I don't have any of
those,' the Tuareg said.
'I only have printed books.'
'Can I take a look?' asked
Haidara.
'Why not?' Haidara opened
the trunk and poured through
the volumes.
Buried among the
printed material
was one work that
caught his eye,
a Koran from the 17th century.
He looked through it carefully,
noting the delicate Maghrebi
letters, the fragile gilt
that caught the late afternoon
light filtering
through the tent flap.
It was, Haidara
realized, a masterpiece.
'How much do you want
for this?' asked Haidara.
'Whatever you want to give
me,' the owner said, shrugging.
'You have to name your price.'
'Give me 5,000 CFA,' or about
$10, the nomad said.
It was a pitifully low sum.
Haidara could not accept it.
They bargained, but
this time the buyer
was bidding up the price.
'No, no.
This treasure has a
huge value,' he replied.
'10,000 CFA.' 'No,'
Haidara said. '20,000.'
Haidara gave him 100,000 CFA.
The man received
the money wide-eyed.
'If I've got more books like,
will you pay for them?' he
asked. 'Of course.'
At five o'clock the morning
after that, in total darkness,
Haidara heard a
knock on his door.
'Who is that?
Haidara said.
The Tuareg entered his room
carrying a large camel skin
sack.
Wordlessly, he dumped a pile
of manuscripts on the ground.
In the murkiness before
dawn, Haidara could barely
see what was lying there.
But at six o'clock, golden light
filtered through his window,
illuminating
magnificent treasure.
When Haidara stepped outside
the hut later that morning,
he stared in astonishment.
Tuaregs from across
the region had
formed a long line in front
of his door, bearing cattle
and sheep skin sacks
stuffed with manuscripts.
Many had been hidden in caves or
holes in the sand for decades.
Haidara handed
out the equivalent
of thousands of dollars--
Kuwait and Saudi
Arabia had subsidized
the effort--
and left with more
than 1,000 manuscripts.
He had paid the
seller's everything
they had demanded an even more.
He had taken
everything they had.
Haidara headed back
up river to Timbuktu,
his boat riding
low in the water,
weighed down with foot lockers
and piles of camel skin sacks.
In Timbuktu, Mahmoud
Zouber, the library curator,
looked on with astonishment.
'You found all that?' he said.
In his first year of work
at the Ahmed Baba Institute,
Haidara managed to acquire
as many manuscripts
as the previous team
of eight prospectors
had collected in a decade."
So I'm going to read one
more section, I think,
that will give you another look
at Abdel Kader and his methods.
Basically, after 12
years of doing this,
he had gotten a bit tired.
It was grueling work,
obviously-- well paid
for Malian standards,
but grueling.
He wanted to get married.
He wanted to settle down.
He was spending three
quarters of his life
on the road in these
incredibly treacherous
and grueling journeys.
He wanted to create
his own library,
as I'd mentioned earlier.
His family had been collecting
these for centuries.
So he informed the
curator, who he'd
become very attached to, that
he wanted to go out on his own.
They began casting
around for money.
He needed money,
obviously, to do this.
Wrote to about 100 different
organizations across the world
and got absolutely nowhere until
Henry Louis Gates of Harvard
University came along.
Now Gates, of course, was one
of America's foremost scholars,
had spent much of
his life trying
to show the world-- trying to
move American and the world
away from a Euro-centric
literary outlook
and show the Africa
actually had been
a center of literary tradition
that was completely lost.
And so he set out in 1996 to
make a documentary with PBS
and BBC backing about Timbuktu,
about African culture,
and arrived in Timbuktu in
1996, and began hearing stories
about this collector
in this town.
And this is how a fateful
meeting between East and West,
between Africa and the--
actually, the developing
world and the developed
world took place.
So Gates gets to Timbuktu, and
shows up with a certain plan,
has never heard of
Haidara, has a certain plan
of going to the mosque
and filming there.
"But when they
reach their hotel,
their translator guide, and
acquaintance of Haidara,
approached them with
a different proposal.
'If you want to see a
real library,' he said,
'these books are held
mostly in private hands.
And there is a man I know who
might be willing to show you
his collection.'
Gates, intrigued,
changed his itinerary.
And he and the film
crew follow his guide
through the back alleys
to Haidara's house.
Haidara, meanwhile, was
growing despondent the library
he had dreamed of creating for
five years was going nowhere.
More than 100 foundations
had turned down his proposal,
and he had run out of ideas.
A big delegation of Americans is
here in Timbuktu,' Gates' guide
informed Haidara on the
morning of the Harvard
professor's arrival.
'They want to visit.
You they want to see
your manuscripts,
so be ready.' Haidara sensed
that the visit could be
an opportunity for him.
'Fine,' he replied.
'I'll prepare something
for them.' Haidara lay down
a carpet and gathered the best
manuscripts in his Timbuktu
collection.
Gates and the film crew
arrived later that day.
As the crew filmed, Gates
leafed through a treatise
on astronomy, a ledger
book that recorded slave
transactions, and other works.
'These are books written by
black people?' Gates asked
Haidara in a scene
captured on camera.
Haidara, a bushy haired and
youthful 33-year-old nods.
'When I was growing
up,' Gates replies,
shaking his head in amazement,
'the school books said that
Africans couldn't read and write
and didn't have any books.'
For hours, Haidara
gave Gates a tutorial
on Timbuktu's literary
heritage, describing
the rise of the
University of Sankore
and its illustrious roster
of biographers, jurists,
and historians, enumerating
the 12 important families that
had accumulated most of
Timbuktu's manuscripts
during its golden age,
chronicling the invasion
by Morocco that drove most
of these volumes underground,
and explaining the role
played by descendants
of Timbuktu's collectors,
who had protected
the works for 400 years.
It was one of the most moving
days of my life,' Gates
recalled. 'I was so
emotional holding these books
in my hands.' Not a word was
spoken about Haidara's stymied
plans to build a library,
but Gates left his encounter
convinced that he had to
do something to preserve
the manuscript.
Unprotected and neglected
storage rooms-- many
we're turning to dust or
being devoured by termites,
and some had already been lost.
It was a bone dry climate in
Timbuktu, so he was lucky,
Gates said.
If they had been stored in
the humidity of Nigeria,
they would've turned
to mush long ago.
When he returned to
the United States,
Gates informed the project
director at the Andrew W Mellon
Foundation in New York City
of the amazing discovery
he had made in Timbuktu.
All of these books still exist.
This guy has them.
And they're not even
in a library,' he said.
Three months later,
on the strength
of Gates' recommendation,
the Mellon Foundation
awarded Haidara grant
of nearly $100,000
for the creation of a new
manuscript center in Timbuktu.
The money came with
strings attached.
Mellon required the collector
to create a digital archive
before moving ahead with
the physical construction.
'I know you want
to build a library,
but the cataloging and
digitization have to come
first,' Gates emphasized.
Haidara expressed his gratitude.
Then he hired an architect
and construction crew
and built the library anyway.
'What?' Gates said when Haidara
informed him several months
later that the
library was complete.
'I told you that you needed to
catalog first.' 'We can't do
that without first having a
building,' Haidara replied.
He argued that the
manuscripts had
been exposed to the
elements and imperiled
in their dusty storage rooms
and that his first priority
was to protect them.
Exasperated and
fearing a scandal,
Gates reported the
misuse of the grant money
to the Mellon Foundation.
They grumbled about it, but
the attitude, says Gates,
was, what's done is done.
A few months later, Haidara
again called Gates at Harvard.
'What is it?' asked
Gates, still annoyed
by Haidara's high-handedness.
'I need another grant to build
another library,' Haidara said.
'What?' Gates
exclaimed once more.
'It's amazing that you've
got a grant to begin
with.' 'I know,' Haidara
said, 'but there was a slight
miscalculation.' 'What are you
talking about?' 'We built it
in the floodplain.
We have to rebuild it.'
As Haidara explained
it, after many years
of little or no
rainfall in Timbuktu,
he and his construction
team had taken for granted
that the building
site was secure.
But that year, a
once-in-a-generation series
of rainstorms had
struck the region.
Rainwater had deluged the
rooms, cracked the cement,
and caused the roof to collapse.
'Everything is filled with
water,' he told Gates.
Luckily, Haidara
had not yet started
moving is manuscripts
into the new library.
And they had all been spared.
Gates, mortified, went back
to the Mellon Foundation.
'You remember that library in
Timbuktu that was built without
your authorization with your
money?' he asked the program
officer.
'Yes,' he replied.
'Well, we've got
to build it again.'
The program director
just laughed.
The whole situation was so quote
'absurd' unquote, said Gates,
and Haidara's demand for
more money so audacious
that it evoked more
amusement than outrage.
The Mellon Foundation decided to
come through the extra funding,
and the Ford Foundation
contributed money as well.
A new building soon rose
on the site, this one built
with reinforced concrete and
with its foundation raised
several feet off the ground.
On January 13th,
2000, in a ceremony
attended by many luminaries,
the Mamma Haidara Commemorative
Library officially opened
its doors to the world."
Well, that was in 2000.
And of course, that was
a high point for Haidara.
And the next few years
would be glory years for him
as he watched this culture
kind of rise out of the desert
and begin to attract
more and more money
and generate more
and more interest.
And it became sort
of an avalanche.
Tourists begat more
media interest,
which begat more money.
All, of course, came
crashing down in 2012
with the takeover of Timbuktu.
And I'm going to save
the smuggling operation
for your own reading.
But of course, that
forms basically
the last 40% of the book as this
elaborate, dangerous operation
to remove the books under the
noses of the Al Qaeda occupiers
unfolds with a
still-- well, I would
stay with a happy, tentatively
happy result, but somewhat
ambiguous given
everything that's
going on in that part
of the world right now.
So at this point,
48 minutes, I'd
be happy to take some questions
from anybody who's got one.
AUDIENCE: How long were
you developing that book?
JOSHUA HAMMER: So I had been
traveling to Mali just out
of my own interest
over, you know--
so I visited in '95 on a
lark, as I said, then 2006.
2008 I went there to do
a whole bunch of stuff.
I was there for three weeks.
I did a story on the
festival, on other projects,
went back to Timbuktu.
Couldn't find
Haidara at that time.
He had just-- but I
went and saw his library
and saw how that had
developed, and then
came back again in 2013
when the French invaded.
Because I knew so many people
that when the jihadists took
over, of course I was
then thinking, well,
what has happened to those-- I
wondered what would happened.
It was hard to get any
information out of the North,
you know?
So it was just like a vacuum.
So I guess it was
around that trip in 2013
then I started to begin
to think about a book.
But it wasn't
necessarily this book.
It was just a book about
this dramatic takeover
of the North in Mali.
And maybe I would follow some
of the characters I knew,
the head of the music festival.
You know, it was all vaguely
formed at that point.
And then I found out
about the manuscripts,
what had happened to them.
I managed to track
down that story.
And then that became sort of
the most interesting element
of the any book idea.
So and I actually then
went back in August, 2013
to write for Smithsonian
about that rescue effort.
And by then, that
was when I said,
yeah, this story, with all the
background, and Haidara's life,
and the rise of jihadism in
North Africa, I said, you know,
all these elements have
the makings of a real tale.
So the book really
began to form then.
And then two more
trips followed to Mali
to kind of both piece together
Abdel Kader's biography
and then to go up to the North
and find out what had happened.
Because that story was also
pretty much unknown, you know.
Some people had gone up
with the French-- brief blip
on the new screen.
But I wanted to go up there,
and spend like a couple weeks
there, and meet people, and just
get that whole account of what
it was like to live under
Islamist Al Qaeda occupation
for almost a years,
you know, where they
were building this caliphate.
Because I thought that was an
important part of the story
so you could kind
of understand what
the dangers that the bad-ass
librarians were up against.
So it needed to be made
as visceral and concrete
as possible.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I had a question.
JOSHUA HAMMER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So for the
families that are
preserving these manuscripts--
JOSHUA HAMMER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --you
mentioned a lot of them
are in classical Arabic.
JOSHUA HAMMER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So did
they, you know, know
the contents of the
manuscripts, or just the fact
that they were historic,
or what they had?
JOSHUA HAMMER: Most didn't.
Most of them didn't
know, actually.
Because Arabic had been kind
of-- although at one time
it was the lingua franca
of that part of the world,
the French conquerors came in.
Arabic fell by the wayside.
French became the
language the people
had to learn in
high schools, those
who went to school, which
especially up in the North
is not a great number.
You know, I think it has one
of the highest-- ironically,
this region that's produced
some of the greatest
literature in Africa now has
one of the highest illiteracy
rates on the continent.
So yeah.
I mean, there was scholarship.
There were people.
But the people
who learned Arabic
tended to be those who-- it
was kept inside the family,
passed down.
Or they traveled
abroad, maybe learned it
in Cairo or whatever.
It was a very small
percentage of who actually
knew what they had, you know?
Yeah.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What's
it like there now?
Is any of that culture
from the early 21st century
been resurrected?
Do the libraries still exist?
JOSHUA HAMMER: The
libraries exist.
And the Ahmed Baba Center,
where those-- is still
a pretty impressive-- I mean,
the South African government
built that.
It's like a $8
million structure.
And I think there are a
couple of curators, you know,
trying to basically just keep
the building from falling
completely to pieces.
But I'm sure that Abdel
Kader's library, which is also
a really impressive-- more
modest building, but impressive
still.
I know he's got a curator
on hand, you know,
keeping it in shape.
The manuscripts are in-- the
are no manuscripts in there.
Well, the Ahmed Baba Center may.
There were about 10,000 books in
the-- the big Ahmed Baba Center
was taken over by
the jihadis early
on and turned into a barracks.
So that when the
smugglers went to work
trying to sneak books
out of the city,
they couldn't go in there.
Basically, they
figured everything
in there was going to be lost.
And in fact, that's where they
torch those 4,000 that I showed
some pictures of the scraps.
But 10,000 of them were in
the basement in a climate
controlled room, locked doors.
And the jihadis, even
though they lived there
for eight months, they
never found out about them.
So those were all preserved.
But again, like 99% of those
manuscripts are down in Bamako
now.
And the libraries are
standing, but they're empty.
And probably, you know, some
of them are falling apart.
But the idea is that one day
when things are safe enough
in Timbuktu, they'll be able
to bring all the books, all
the manuscripts back
and reopen the libraries
[SPEAKING ARABIC].
Who knows when that
day will happen?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOSHUA HAMMER: Well, the
Ahmed Baba Center's books
have been digitized.
All those manuscripts have.
There had been a big program
funded by the South Africans
not only to restore the actual
works but to digitize them.
But that Ahmed
Baba Center really
comprises a small percentage
of this overwhelming 400,000.
And I think the majority of
those have not been digitized.
There's a plan intact now.
They're all kind of
sitting in storage rooms,
in climate controlled rooms.
But there's no laboratory-- just
storage facilities, you know?
And I don't know if
there are laboratories.
I really don't know what's
going on in that regard.
Abdel Kader was supposed to
be getting money together.
I did read it there is this,
interestingly enough, a monk,
a Minnesota based
monk, who has been--
and I may even go off and try
to do something about him.
There's a piece in "The
Economist" about him.
He's had a long
interest in manuscripts
from the Middle East.
He did preserve the masters of
Homs and Aleppo before the war.
And he has made contact
with Abdel Kader Haidara.
And I think that has certainly
begun this digitization
process.
He's visited Bamako a few times.
I think I heard that he's
on his way there now.
So he might be the only
one actually actively doing
this now.
But his specialty is in
fact digitization of works.
He's got into it through
medieval Italian Catholic
manuscripts and then kind of
gradually expand its interests.
So yeah.
I'd be interested to
find out what he's up to.
MALE SPEAKER: Having said that,
thanks a lot for speaking--
JOSHUA HAMMER: Thanks.
MALE SPEAKER: --with
us today and sharing
the inspirational story.
Thank you.
JOSHUA HAMMER: You're welcome.
[APPLAUSE]